okay welcome overtime we're here with
Minnesota congressman and 2024
Democratic presidential candidate Dean
Phillips host of FY zakar at GPS on CNN
for Zari and president ofal group and G
media Ian Brer here are the questions
I'm rushing because I got to get to
Vegas uh this is for you congressman who
would you choose to be your running mate
oh good question I didn't ask you that
oh I have to choose a different person
now well your running mate my running
mate yeah it's way too early for for
that I I I will surprise you I promise
you that I promise you that I will
surprise you I will I'll will absolutely
surprise you with a running M good
surprise or bad good
surprise yeah that's it almost sounded
like a threat I I promise you really I
will surprise you it's not katop is
it katop all right I love them but I I I
don't now katop had two higher demands
all right I mean I can't give away I
can't give away this stuff ear I know
you want all right did Democrats make a
strategic error by not saving Kevin
McCarthy now that we're stuck with a
much more extreme speaker of the house
that's an interesting question well
there really they could have right
there's a danger of a really I mean you
were alluding to this of a of a real
political constitutional crisis because
right Trump is going to be the nominee
so one of two things are going to happen
in 2024 he's either going to win that
has its own problems or he's going to
claim he won exactly those are the only
two options absolutely I'm said it for
seven years and he's going to show up
but this time Inauguration Day January
2025 he will show up but but this time
say the Pennsylvania state legislature
where the laws I think have been changed
where they can send an alternate uh
slate of of electors and who do they
send them to the Speaker of the House
Mike Johnson who is who is going to be
very willing to hear all the stuff that
at least Kevin McCarthy in the crunch
right let me let me tell you guys it's
important everybody know this we
extended a number of overtures to
speaker McCarthy a number of other
Republicans saying we want to work
together just make some modest
concessions first of all make the house
work that was our first demand not one
of them would speak to us because they
knew if they actually attracted a single
Democratic vote let alone 10 15 20 that
they would be eviscerated by their
brothers and sisters on their side that
is that is the culture of Congress that
is absolutely destroying the country
that's the culture the culture of the
house the culture of the house it's not
the Senate but no it's not that is true
not the Senate that is the truth I heard
you say before when we were talking that
you know you're going to stop this and
we got to work together everybody says
that what's the plan what's the plan to
do that you just said they wouldn't even
talk to you what I what's the
plan oh no no
no well it begins it begins with the
surprise running mate yes that it
begin I mean it
look
I as the I was the most bipartisan
member of Congress last year the second
most this year I really do I love my
brothers and sisters on both side there
are some wonderful Republicans who I
think have a chance to rise I think want
to work together uh this wasn't the time
to do it uh but wish to do so and there
are some outstanding but again how do
you liberate them from this problem
you're talking about where that's why
I'm running for look I'm running for
president to win I believe we can I
believe it's time for a new generation
does anybody agree by the
way and
and you know the the last time in
American history I think a president
really accomplished the notion of a Team
of Rivals was AB Lincoln and I do think
it's time I really do believe it's time
for a Democratic president to ensure
that there are conservative voices in
The White House at within the cabinet uh
having his or her ear and vice versa it
should go the other way as well I'll do
so and I think so that's why running for
president you can actually break this
loock by actually I know what the
surprise is yeah oh no I no no no but
you're hinting that you would have your
team of rival somebody else so that your
vice president would be I'm not saying I
am I'm saying I would not rule that out
saying you might you should have teasing
it you're saying you might just say it
just say it it's ramama Swami it's
only oh no that I that I think I can
promise you it a it ain't it ain't but
somebody like but like all right so we
won't say it's your VP but like who are
some of the more reasonable Republicans
who if that was your the direction you
were going into well first of all I
think we lost two of our great young
conservatives in Anthony Gonzalez uh
Pete Meyer they V they had the audacity
they had the audacity to vote to impeach
Trump 10 of them nine of them got thrown
out of the house essentially I will tell
you that Dusty Johnson uh a very
principled good person Dusty Johnson
Dusty Johnson who's that you don't know
I don't know I thought I thought he was
some
old Dy
Johnson remember Dusty Johnson yeah no
nobody knows nobody know you're going to
be on the show next
week phips Johnson that's these if I out
my friends they're going to lose their
races I don't want to do it very
sincerely the problem is they're the
workhorses not the show horses you don't
know their you know Lauren bobbert and
margerie Taylor green and Jim Jordan
because they're destructive tired of it
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney he's a gentleman
he's a gentleman and he's and he's
principal and he already ran he's a
known quantity I mean yes a lot of
people hate him but like no but like but
he stood he stood strong he's one of
those what I call As Good As It Gets
Republicans Liz Cheney Liz I sat with
Liz Cheney on January they hate but they
principal right now and it's a shame Liz
Cheney had principal she got thrown out
of the house I was with her on January 6
when she looked at the television screen
Donald Trump on it she said he's
responsible we're going to hold him to
account the whole room erupted Democrats
and Republicans a year later look who
was left so okay last question RFK is
leading among I read young people and
independents and in a three-way race uh
he gets now like higher
22% I mean that's pretty amazing what
you but he takes more from Trump takes
more from Trump takes more from Trump
you know I mean he's sort of dominating
The Conspiracy Theory Lane which is a
lane now in US politics um and if he
continues to run as opposed to like the
No Labels Joe Mansion fever dream which
I think was never going to happen um
then it actually gives Biden more of a
shot and at the end of the day if good
Dean Phillips doesn't somehow make it to
take Biden out um then you're going to
need to have Biden be able to do it and
a third party candidate may actually
help on that front I mean the
fundamental problem all of these
scenarios are terrifying is we don't
actually have a real election right I
mean Biden will win probably by 9
million votes but the most powerful man
will
right popular vote he won by heon by
seven and a half last time oh I'm glad
you're so sanguin about that I am what
I'm not sang about is lose no but but
even if he if I didn't think he was
going to lose I wouldn't be all
in
not Dean Phillips I've said it for
years for God's
[Applause]
sake Johnson no but the point is it's
going to be decided in four states right
I mean the the Electoral College is what
matters yes Biden will win the the the
popular vote the problem is don't know
that four states Pennsylvania Arizona
Georgia Wisconsin does matter and you're
of them guys he's down in each of the
Battleground States right now that's one
reason I'm doing this we have to do this
Al I got to go to Vegas thank you very
[Applause]
much